[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
nigeria
schönen guten abend ich bin neu hier
kommen jetzt öfter und freue mich sehr
dass sie dabei sind sowie kristin otto
für den sport freue mich auch guten
abend ja es ist eine intensive
nachrichtenlage wir wollen sie in den
nächsten minuten für sie sortieren heute
unter anderem mit diesen themen
[Musik]
krisentreffen bei der cdu nach dem
wahl-desaster soll ein parteitag die
gesamte führung neu wählen
vereidigung in österreich alexander
schallenberg wird neuer kanzler nach dem
rücktritt von sebastian kurz
und jetzt wird selbst gezahlt corona
schnelltests sind seit heute
kostenpflichtig
[Musik]
beginnen wir mit den heftigen
turbulenzen in der cdu da liegen nach
der heftigen wahlschlappe bei vielen die
nerven blank heute beschlossen die
cdu-spitzen dass ein parteitag die
komplette führungsriege neu bestimmen
soll möglicherweise auch unter
einbindung der basis das wurde zuletzt
ja immer lauter gefordert über die
größte cdu krise seit vielen jahren und
die suche nach lösungen ines trams
gremiensitzungen im konrad-adenauer-haus
wie so oft montags und doch geht es
heute um nichts weniger als den fahrplan
in die zukunft der partei um
neuausrichtung von personal und inhalten
geht doch nicht nur neue gesichter
sondern es geht darum dass die partei
dass die cdu noch mal neuen sound für
sich entwickelt nach fünf stunden
sitzung drängen sich norbert röttgen und
jens spahn zwei der möglichen kandidaten
für den parteivorsitz
wortlos an den kameras vorbei unklar
nach wie vor ob es einen konsens
kandidaten geben kann armin laschet wird
in den nächsten tagen auch gespräche
führen mit den vereinigungen mit den
landesverbänden um auch dort wie sagt
man so schön das ohr ans gleis zu legen
um zu wissen was da auf uns alle zukommt
und möglicherweise auch darüber zu
sprechen wie könnte eine lösung aussehen
das wahlergebnis soll aufgearbeitet
werden mit externen experten auch eine
ost konferenz einstimmig beschlossen die
gremien den gesamten bundesvorstand neu
zu bestimmen auch wenn dieser vorstand
gerade erst gewählt wurde also zu beginn
dieses jahres das
wieder es eine neue legitimation braucht
und alle positionen zur wahl stehen
werden auf dem nächsten bundesparteitag
offen wie die parteimitglieder bei der
auswahl der neuen spitze mitreden dürfen
die kreisvorsitzenden sollen das ende
oktober beraten junge abgeordnete wie
nadine schön wollen dass mehr auf die
basis gehört wird bei personal und
ausrichtungen der kreisvorsitzenden ist
ja der erste richtige schritt die
kreisvorsitzenden das sind diejenigen
die wirklich vor ort hören wie die
stimmung ist was die parteimitglieder
denken aber eben auch was die menschen
denken was wer wie all diese fragen sind
nach wie vor offen bei der cdu auch nach
den gremiensitzungen dieses montags
die christdemokraten wollen die gesamte
führungsspitze neu wählen lassen schenk
unterlag energy in berlin die cdu so wie
wir sie kennen könnte es die bald
vielleicht nicht mehr geben
tatsächlich verbinden viele in der
partei mit den heute angekündigten
maßnahmen die hoffnung auf eine
runderneuerung der cdu und das jetzt
nicht nur das präsidium neu gewählt
werden soll sondern sich der gesamte
bundesvorstand zur neuwahl stellt das
kann man schon als versuch eines echten
neustart werten die frage ist nur klappt
das dann am ende der mir manchmal guckt
wer sich jetzt wer jetzt für den
parteivorsitz für die nachfolge von
armin laschet im gespräch ist zumindest
momentan da sind doch viele alte nahmen
dabei die beim letzten mal auch schon
dabei waren friedrich merz norbert
röttgen jens spahn ein paar junge namen
fangen auch schon an zu kursieren
carsten linnemann hat man hier schon
einmal gehört aber der hat sich noch gar
nicht geäußert ob er überhaupt ins
rennen gehen will also die frage ist wer
tritt dort an und wird es tatsächlich so
wie armin laschet sich das vorstellt
dass es am ende keine kampfkandidatur
gibt alles noch vollkommen offen der
versuch heute auch über mehr
mitgliederbeteiligung ein zeichen zu
setzen der ist auf jeden fall gemacht
aber ob dann die erneuerung der cdu
tatsächlich klappt steht erst am ende
des prozesses fest aufwühlende zeiten
für die cdu fiel dank unterlag banerjee
ja und während die union
also noch sortiert noten andere ihre
chancen auf eine neue
regierungskoalition aus rot grün und
gelb reden miteinander und zwar gleich
drei mal diese woche zum auftakt kamen
die spitzen von grünen und fdp
demonstrativ gemeinsam zum tagungsort in
gesprächen mit der spd soll alles auf
den tisch gerade zum großen streit thema
finanzen und es bleibt beim stil der
vergangenen tage über die inhalte wurde
vertraulichkeit vereinbart erst zum ende
der woche könnte es eine art zwischen
fazit geben
und jetzt zum machtkampf in der afg
parteichef jörg merten hat angekündigt
beim parteitag im dezember nicht mehr
für den vorsitz zu kandidieren
damit sind die internen grabenkämpfe
offenbar vorerst entschieden zwischen
der rechtsaußen strömung um coach krupp
aller und fraktionschefin beide und den
gemäßigteren lager um leuten hat es
zuletzt immer wieder kontroversen auf
offener bühne über ausrichtung oder über
den kurs der partei gegeben fragen wir
nach bei theo koll in berlin tu was
passiert in einer afd in der jörg meuten
kein chef mehr sein wird
nur das wird auch davon abhängen wer den
machtkampf um die nachfolge für sich
entscheiden kann aber schon jetzt hat
sich das machtgefüge der partei weiter
nach rechts verschoben richtung noch
radikaler der angekündigte rückzug von
jörg leuten ist also folge und symbole
genau diese entwicklung leuten hatte ja
hin beispielsweise für die abspaltung
des extremen rechten flügel plädierte
hatte dessen chef strategen kalbitz aus
der partei ausschließen lassen aber das
waren offensichtlich nur scheinbare
siege meuten hat es nicht geschafft
diesen völkisch nationalen flügel in die
schranken zu weisen erst im august ist
er gescheitert ein landesvize der sich
selbst als freundliches gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnet hatte aus
der partei auszuschließen bei der
bundestagswahl hat die fdp im osten
deutlich mehr sitze gewonnen bundesweit
aber hat sie ein fünftel ihrer wähler
verloren das heißt ein künftig noch
radikalerer kurs dürfte also den
einfluss der östlichen landesverbände
vergrößern das wählerspektrum insgesamt
aber wahrscheinlich weiter fan theo
vielen dank für die einordnung jetzt der
blick auf das polit beben in österreich
dort wurde heute ein neuer bundeskanzler
vereidigt der bisherige aussenminister
alexander schallenberg ein enger
vertrauter des alten regierungschefs
sebastian kurz und der trat er am
samstag wegen korruptionsermittlungen
gegen ihn zurück aber kurz verlässt die
politische bühne nichts im gegenteil
kritiker sprechen vom neuen schatten
kanzler im hintergrund wolf christian
ullrich jetzt mit den einzelheiten
österreichs neuer bundeskanzler steht
zwischen allen fronten er soll es dem
grünen koalitionspartner recht machen
und den kurz getreuen im kanzleramt
als spitzendiplomat und außenminister
wissen sie genau wie man die
gegensätzlichen positionen auf einen
gemeinsamen nenner bringt nach seiner
vereidigung zeigte schallenberg gleich
im ersten statement wo er steht nämlich
absolut loyal gegenüber seinem
ehemaligen chef sebastian kurz der
zurückgetreten war weil die
staatsanwaltschaft gegen ihn wegen
anstiftung zur bestechung und untreue
ermittelt ich werde selbstverständlich
mit sebastian kurz zu eng
zusammenarbeiten
alles andere wäre demokratiepolitisch
absurd
zudem halte ich die im raum stehenden
vorwürfe für falsch kanzler schallenberg
von kurzen gnaden dieser eindruck bleibt
heute haften kurz selbst dementierte
dann auch sofort zitat ich bin kein
schatten kanzler es war vollkommen klar
dass alexander schallenberg inhaltlich
um keinen zentimeter von sebastian kurz
abrückt und er hat sich sehr weit
vorgewagt nämlich in der rolle des
bundeskanzlers nicht als privatmeinung
dass er sozusagen auch der justiz
ausgerichtet hat ich glaube der ist
unschuldig die grünen die kurz rücktritt
wollten üben sich nun in optimismus ich
gehe davon aus dass wir dann auch
in dieser funktion von sebastian kurz
eine gute zusammenarbeit haben nach zwei
jahren als außenminister plötzlich
bundeskanzler eine unerwartete karriere
für den 52 jährigen alexander
schallenberg seine politische
gestaltungskraft jedoch hängt derzeit
von sebastian kurz ab
bei der parlamentswahl im irak da gibt
es erste ergebnisse demnach ist die vom
populistischen geistlichen al-sadr
angeführte schiitische strömung stärkste
kraft an der wahl hatten sich so wenige
menschen beteiligt wie noch nie nur 41
prozent der wahlberechtigten gaben ihre
stimme ab die wahl war als reaktion auf
die anhaltende krise im land und
massenproteste gegen die regierung
vorgezogen worden
und wir schauen auf die pandemie lage in
deutschland
und da könnte der alltag in kroner
zeiten von heute an für viele deutlich
teurer werden seit märz gab es ja die
kostenlosen corona schnelltest bezahlt
vom staat seit heute ist schluss damit
ungeimpfte die einen negativen kurve
test nachweis brauchen die müssen jetzt
selber zeit allerdings gibt es ausnahmen
und die details die bringt uns jetzt
stefan schlössern er
ab sofort nicht mehr bürger test
kostenlos seit heute ist damit schluss
jetzt musste abstrich von den meisten
aus eigener tasche bezahlt werden in
ordnung weil die leute hat nicht so
lange zeit sich impfen zu lassen es ist
sehr praktisch für die leute halt wenn
sie irgendwas aufsuchen wollen kulturell
oder so halt aber ich denke mal auf die
dauer kann der staat das wahrscheinlich
nicht packe ich finde es ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich blöd weil ich denke dass es
wieder so erzwangen durch die hintertür
die preise sind nicht festgelegt die
anbieter entscheiden selbst
verbraucherschützer raten deshalb genau
hinzuschauen die preisspanne ist sehr
groß bewegt sich zwischen 10 bis 40 euro
das heißt da ist es wirklich ratsam
mehrere angebote zu vergleichen und
nicht einfach zum erstbesten zu gehen um
sich testen zu lassen es gibt aber
ausnahmen vor allem für kinder unter
zwölf jahren bleiben die tests
kostenfrei für unter 18 jährige
zumindest bis jahresende
auch für schwangere in den ersten drei
monaten ihrer schwangerschaft und aus
medizinischen gründen ebenso der test
zum beenden einer corona quarantäne
ausgeschlossen werde dadurch niemand
meint der ethikrat sie können sich
jederzeit impfen lassen oder eben halt
kostenpflichtig testen lassen das ist
der ausschluss ihrer freiheits
entscheidungen die müssen weg kommen
dass wir sagen freiheits entscheidung ja
aber die vorteile gewinne ich und die
nachteile pahlig ab viele test center
werden dicht machen deutlich weniger
menschen sich testen lassen mit
negativen folgen befürchten experten
insofern verlieren wir natürlich einen
gewissen überblick über das
infektionsgeschehen weil wir gerade
dieses niederschwellige angebot immer
sehr wichtig ist um eben auch fälle zu
identifizieren infektionsketten
unterbrechen zu können
doch die entscheidung steht der druck
gerade auf ungeimpfte stadt
ja was also gibt's künftig bei den
schnelltests zu bedenken alle fragen und
antworten zum thema finden sie in
unserer zdf heute nochmal
zusammengefasst und auch dazu wie
überhaupt überprüft wird wer weiterhin
kostenlose tests für sich beanspruchen
darf
das wird uns jetzt zum blick auf die
neuinfektionen in deutschland das robert
koch institut meldet 3111 ansteckungen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 23 mehr
als vor einer woche die sieben tage
instituts steigt auf 66,5 so hoch lag
sie zuletzt vor gut zwei wochen
drei semester studieren ohne die uni von
innen gesehen zu haben hunderttausende
studentinnen und studenten haben das
erlebt oder besser gesagt erlitten aber
diese zeit soll jetzt mit beginn des
wintersemesters zu ende seien seminare
und vorlesungen finden wieder analog
stadt jedenfalls für geimpfte für
getestete und genesen die
herausforderung ist das zu organisieren
und zu kontrollieren der beitrag von
thomas münten beginnt in einer etwas
anderen aula
studien bescheinigung stadt
mannschaftsaufstellung wo sonst der
erste fc köln um bundesligapunkte spielt
wurden heute die studierenden an der
kölner universität begrüßt
präsenzstudium zum ersten mal seit
anderthalb jahren wieder
13.000 studenten haben ein ticket
gekauft der soziale kontakt hat gefehlt
werden ein semester präsenz und dann
natürlich nur noch online deswegen sind
wir jetzt mal gespannt wie es weiter
geht heute morgen auch viel verkehr an
der düsseldorfer universität olivia
böttcher und antonia weber kehren zurück
beide hatten nur ein präsent semester
bisher ich bin ein bisschen überwältigt
also ich hab den campus schon sehr sehr
lange nicht mehr so viel erlebt und ich
freue mich irgendwie auch weil sich doch
trotz masken und abständen wieder ein
bisschen normaler anfühlt als davor
auch wenn viele es nicht so ist wie vor
der pandemie wenn das café nur to go
verkauft bei den meisten überwiegt die
freude
ich glaube das ist jetzt schon erstmals
im uni alltag dazu gehören wird aber ich
glaube damit sind wir auch alle
zufrieden also es ist okay wir freuen
uns alle dass wir überhaupt wieder in
die uni gehen können
natürlich melden sich auch kritiker zu
wort die das enge miteinander für
gefährlich halten aber die studierenden
haben das sehr begeistert wenn am ersten
tag schon dreieinhalb tausend bewegungen
jetzt 13.000 es gab eigentlich zu dieser
veranstaltung jetzt überhaupt keine
kritischen stimmen ab morgen ist die
party dann vorbei und das heißt wieder
ganz normal studieren
[Musik]
studierende im stadion welche erfolgen
haben entscheidungen in wirtschaft und
politik für den arbeitsmarkt mit fragen
wie diese beschäftigen sich die drei
forscher david card joshua r ist und
guido in binz und dafür bekommen sie nun
den wirtschaftsnobelpreis alle drei
arbeiten in den usa mit ihren speziellen
analysemethoden konnte etwa nachgewiesen
werden dass ein steigender mindestlohn
nicht zwangsläufig jobs kostet sie
erforschten auch wie sich ein
wanderungen auf das lohn und
beschäftigungsniveau auswirkt jetzt
etwas völlig anderes es geht um
journalismus und medien konsum da gibt
es unterschiedliche wahrnehmungen auf
der einen seite da wird uns immer wieder
eine hohe glaubwürdigkeit bescheinigt
gleichzeitig hören wir aber auch auf den
vorwurf die politik würde unsere inhalte
beeinflussen wie wir berichten und
welche themen wir beleuchten bestimmt
tatsächlich wir alleine allerdings
glauben in deutschland laut einer
umfrage 35 prozent dass die regierung
den medien vorgaben macht und auch sonst
ist vielen menschen nicht klar wie die
medien genau funktionieren als erstes
bundesland hat sachsen jetzt eine
repräsentative studie zum thema
durchgeführt und die bringt uns jetzt
stefan kern er
nicht weiß wie medien funktionieren weiß
auch nicht wie demokratie funktioniert
zu diesem schluss kommt eine sächsische
studie zur medienkompetenz befragt
wurden dafür 2500 sachsen ein drittel
der sachsen
versteht nicht so richtig wie medien
funktionieren und 20 prozent glauben
sogar dass die medien in staatsbesitz
sind befragt nach ihrer funktion
antworten 35 prozent dass medien die
meinungsbildung lenken sollen 22 prozent
glauben dass medien den interessen von
staat und kapital dienen
bestehe den mainstream sogenannten
mainstream medien insofern kritisch
gegenüber als ich meine dass die
nachweislich einer bestimmten sichtweise
verpflichtet sind das hzb gar kein
fernsehen auch nachrichten lese ich auch
zeitungen überhaupt nicht also wirklich
ernsthaft nur social media kanäle die
klassischen medien versuchen darauf zu
reagieren
transparenz gegen leserschwund
beschwerden und beschimpfungen wir haben
ja schon maßnahmen ergriffen und schon
seit geraumer zeit wir haben einen
ombudsmann der jedem sonnabend auf der
leserforum seite zu fragen von lesern
stellung nimmt und dessen teil fragen
wie hat die sächsische zeitung ein
corona staatsauftrag oder wer bezahlt
eigentlich unsere schreiber und unserer
artikel die studie fördert mediale
bildungsarbeit damit hat der freistaat
sachsen bereits begonnen die lehrpläne
sind überarbeitet medienerziehung wurde
in alle fächer eingebogen eine
engagierte lehrer und erwachsenenbildung
soll nun aufgebaut werden für eine
künftig bessere medienkompetenz im
freistaat
ja und wie das bei uns im zdf läuft wie
beiträge für die nachrichten entstehen
und wie wir unsere themen auswählen auch
das können sie nachlesen in unserer zdf
heute
damit wenn wir jetzt beim sport und bei
dir und einem schönen mix großartiger
triumph für die deutschen
beachvolleyballerinnen karla borger und
julia sude das duo gewann zum
saisonabschluss in italien das
prestigeträchtige endspiel der world
tour das turnier der zehn besten teams
der welt
sie können ihre siegesserien kaum fassen
als wahrer favoritenschreck haben sich
karla borger und julia sude durch die
endrunde der world tour gespielt und
behalten auch im finale die nerven gegen
die kanadischen weltmeisterinnen kevin
human japan rede gewinnen sie satz eins
überlegen mit 21 zu 13 im zweiten satz
machen sie es spannend erst mit dem
vierten matchball sichern sie sich den
sieg und überraschend vor allem sich
selbst
dann können das ist einfach wirklich für
uns zwei was ganz besonderes für die
deutschen ist es nach dem frühen aus in
tokio ein perfekter saisonabschluss
20.000 läufer am start des boston
marathons der wegen der pandemie um ein
halbes jahr verschoben wurde den sieg
bei den männern sicherte sich nach knapp
zwei stunden und zehn minuten vincent
kipruto aus kenia ist zeit bei den
frauen lief seine landsfrau diana
kipchoge in gut zwei stunden und 25
minuten
tennis olympiasieger alexander zverev
hat sich durch seinen zweitrunden erfolg
beim masters in indian wells für das
atp-finale in turin qualifiziert an dem
mitte november die besten acht profis
des jahres teilnehmen und fußball
weltmeister frankreich hat mit dem sieg
in der nations league allen grund zum
jubeln das 2 1 in mailand gegen spanien
allerdings nicht ganz unumstritten diese
szene erregt die gemüter steilpass auf
dem papier der franzose überwindet
torwart simon die spanischen
abwehrspieler heben die hand das war
doch eine klare abseitsstellung
schiedsrichter taylor lässt die szene
überprüfen und entscheidet regulärer
treffer papier steht zwar erkennbar im
abseits aber durch das rein gretchen von
garcia wird die richtung des balles
minimal verändert neue spielsituation
eine sehr umstrittene szene die dieses
finale entscheidet zuvor zwei
sehenswerte treffer für spanien durch
raser ball dann der ausgleich durch
benzemas kunstschuss der sieg durch
einen zweifelhaften treffer tut dem
jubel der franzosen über den gewinn der
nations league jedoch keinen abbruch
ja und das ist schöner trost für die
verkorkste
allerdings christine und ich könnte
ihnen jetzt schon vom wetter folgendes
verraten die nächte werden milder die
tage dafür kälter und wie das
zusammenpasst das erzählten gleich katja
horneffer
22.10 empfehlen wir das heute journal
mit claus kleber die heute redaktion
sagt danke fürs zuschauen wünscht an den
entspannten montagabend und gerne wieder
bis morgen um 7
[Musik]